it is really valuable to have someone
who
has direct contact with the customers
also involved in building the product
and so
that's kind of what led me to be in a
more
technical role and to um eventually have
a team of engineers on my own
jennifer richard thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders how are
you
doing well thank you and thanks for
having me
thank you very much for being here and
it started off being an english
major and somehow you find your way into
tech but not just tech you're going
across a being a founding member of a
few different ventures
and venture-backed ventures and then a
climbing into the vc space
at the second fun i believe that you're
at now and now you're a principal at
bonfire ventures
leading a seed stage rounds and tell me
a little bit about your background and
how do you
transition from a english major to doing
what you're doing today
yeah so i think a lot of it was just um
some opportunistic moves and a little
bit of luck
but i have always enjoyed writing i
when i went to college i knew that i
wanted to
pursue english and was thinking about
maybe going into law
after that um i quickly realized
after taking a couple of law classes
that that wasn't what i wanted to do
and um i ended up graduating and just
not having any idea and it was also
during the last
um financial crash so not a lot of
um opportunities in terms of jobs so i
ended up moving
into entertainment working at caa
which is one of the world's biggest
talent agencies
was there for about three years went
through the trainee program there
and in that time we represented people
like eric reese
gary vaynerchuk um and several other
just huge entrepreneurs and what they
were doing seemed a lot more interesting
than
what i was doing and i saw there was a
blossoming tech ecosystem
happening in la and so i decided to take
the leap
uh joined a startup just scaling
customer support at first
after a couple of months that company
was acquired and i got to move into
a more technical role at the founder's
next pivot and so
um from there that's kind of what
started uh
just my career in tech building
companies selling them
building and eventually i decided that
uh
you know what the our investors were
doing also seemed really interesting and
went to school to uh ultimately move
into bc
and that's uh how i made my way where i
am right now
right so you're doing your mba in
berkeley with the with the hope to to
make it into the the vc space what was
it about the vc space that
really resonated with you that you felt
compelling for you to go and work there
yeah so i think there were a couple of
things um
the biggest one was that you know i
worked
uh at a couple of different startups and
like most startups
uh there were some issues with our
culture and
you know issues with diversity and
i realized how hard it is to make the
change from within
um within the company it really was
um our investors who had the most power
and the people who are deploying the
capital who have the most influence on
what the ecosystem looks like
um literally and so i think that was my
biggest motivating factor
to get into vc was to be able to
influence you know who's getting money
you know
what kind of responsibilities they have
holding
founders accountable and and also just
being able to
you know support this ecosystem i love
without being
in siloed into one company and always
working on
one specific problem and so i think that
you know the blend of those two things
is what makes bc a perfect fit for
me and ever since i moved in a few years
ago i just love it
i i love that so take me back a little
bit to this
transition in your career and growing up
did you imagine
that you'll go into tech that that
you'll be you know an
investor at a vc fund especially this
young
um no absolutely not i
didn't even know what packing bc was
when i was growing up
i'm first generation college and
um you know just a lot of a lot of the
things that i'm doing now i just had no
exposure to when i was a kid and so when
i was growing up
you know the things i thought of were
the very traditional
doctor lawyer um
those kinds of career paths i just
didn't even know that this one was an
option
wow so and and what really was it that
made that
that's what so you mentioned that you
were you were part of the company they
got acquired that and then you
transitioned into a more techy role
but but it sounds like that it there's a
little bit more meat there in terms of
you know the thought process
of of making that transition what what
was what was that like
and what were some of the things that
perhaps either surprised you or
disappointed you
in that transition yeah i mean
when i was a kid so probably in
elementary school middle school i taught
myself how to code
and so that is definitely
what influenced me to uh get into a more
technical role
while i was in startups and um
you know i think so i was running
customer support at this first
uh at this first company at this first
startup i was at
and what was so interesting to me was
that we were getting in
so many different you know valuable
pieces of insight from our customers
but there wasn't really a established
communication channel
between support and the engineers who
were
you know building out our product and so
i was constantly you know pinging the
entre uh the
engineers you know telling them we've
gotten this feedback from our customers
i think we should make this change on
the site
and um at first i got some pushback as i
think support managers often do
excuse me but eventually
our cto and our engineering team
realized you know this is affecting our
bottom line
and so it is really valuable to have
someone who
has direct contact with the customers
also involved in
building the product and so that's kind
of what led
me to be in a more technical role and to
um eventually have a team of engineers
on my own
unbelievable and what were some of the
most exciting um
things about being a founding member of
a few venture-backed companies
what were some of the you know the
highlights and you know perhaps for
people that
aren't from tech or aren't from you know
the vc scene that
they they're curious to hear about that
founding member experience
yeah i mean i think that the biggest is
you know starting from absolutely
nothing and just
having this idea of a product and then
launching our mvp and just
you know knowing that it could be so
much better but just having a super
crappy product
and then just being able to constantly
see this evolution
and being in rooms where you know you
can take one path or another
and um weighing out the pros and cons
and then
executing on these different um
you know on these different decisions
and just seeing the way that it
impacts um the company i think that of
course
the biggest um you know the most
memorable moment was
finding out that we were being acquired
and just seeing
you know years of work turn into
um something big and so you know i think
that there's so many
highs and lows in building a company and
it requires
so much um teamwork and
and camaraderie and the people that i
worked with at those startups
are still some of my closest friends and
so
um just being in the trenches with with
a team of people
and having a singular vision and and
getting it done it was just incredible
right which aspects of the
entrepreneurial experience do you take
with you
and your role as principal at vc funds
yeah so i think it's really interesting
that vc funds are
very small typically and so there is a
very
similar feeling of you know wearing
several different hats like for instance
at bonfire
i'm sourcing investments i'm doing
diligence but i'm also doing marketing
for the firm
and um helping with strategy and so
there's no responsibility that's too big
or too small
and that's very similar to the mentality
you have to have
um working in a startup or starting an
early stage company because
um you know i can empathize with the
with our founders very much because
it's a lot of us just doing everything
and trying to pull things together to
make this um this thing work
and um you know we have a similar
feeling of grittiness
and um and yeah i mean i guess that
that's kind of my answer
so tell me a little bit about your your
perspective
um in the vc space whether it's sourcing
deals or doing due diligence
what are some of the things that you're
particularly looking for as
either you're looking for for an
interesting company to source and to
communicate with or
in the due diligence process as a
possible investment opportunity
yeah so i think that question is twofold
because i'm
always looking for um
the right company and product market fit
and growing market and
you know so the right opportunity from
the company perspective and the product
perspective
as well as the right teams to support
and i think that the teams
are really because i going
back to who you know what i said
previously about having this opera
this responsibility to impact culture
and the landscape and who's getting
um capital i want to invest in good
people
and people who um are strong leaders and
who want to empower their teams and have
diverse companies and so
i think that's one and then on the other
side
i want to invest in products that are
going to
change the world you know if i would
have been in bc
um back when you know investors were
uh writing texts into uber seed round or
airbnb
and just being able to um invest in
companies that fundamentally change the
way that people
uh work and operate um is always the
ultimate goal and so
any type of company that is um you know
impacting a large growing market
and um it's providing a software
solution to help people
you know work more efficiently live more
efficiently that's something i'm really
interested in
right do you do you feel there's enough
fair access for people that don't come
from the tech world into the tech world
and i'm asking this because
you know it seems that they're you know
especially 2020 is showing us
uh that you know diversity inclusion is
is
still an issue um everywhere everywhere
in the world
also in the us and one of the things
that i've been thinking about
is the opportunities that are presented
and
breaking the cycles and you're
mentioning that you're a first
generation college student and you
didn't even think about you know going
into tech let alone be a vc
and one of the things that i've been
curious and challenging my thought
process with is
what what are some things that that
really should happen in order for
for this industry to become more
accessible whether it's through training
or through
job opportunities or or you know entry
positions to get people into the right
into the hooks because you mentioned
that one of the things that got you in
there
was a position that you transferred to
once you were already
sort of half a leg into this so i'd love
to hear your perspective
and and what do you think we could
improve on or we could do
yeah so i mean i think that there are
several
angles with which we have to tackle this
problem
i mean a big one is having more diverse
czech writers
which you know is is a big topic of
conversation right now
um another one is increasing the access
to stem programs in um
schools that you know house minority
students
which tend to be completely underfunded
um but i think that the biggest issue
right now
is that you know once these
underrepresented founders investors etc
actually get into a vc fund or get into
a startup um those environments
aren't inclusive and so many of them end
up leaving and taking a different career
path
and so i think that so much of this um
needs to happen at the personal level
for
leaders of these funds and companies to
do the personal work of understanding
empathy
understanding what it means to have an
inclusive culture
and that work is really tough and a lot
of people are afraid of it a lot of
people avoid it but i think that's what
happened for us to turn the needle to
move the needle right so how do you
how do you break that cycle then because
like you mentioned a lot of people are
afraid of it a lot of people don't even
know where to start it's a taboo subject
in a lot of
you know in a lot of people's minds and
you know it's like a chicken and the egg
you need to have diversity in order for
it to
become less of a taboo subject but you
don't have the diversity because it is a
taboo subject so
so how how do you think we can we can
potentially start moving the needle in
the right direction
and perhaps it's just a you know a
generational thing and the new
generation of
perhaps entrepreneurs are growing up in
a more diverse world but
what do you think could happen already
right now as
you know somebody who's leading
investments who's helping promote
certain companies what what do you think
should happen
yeah i mean i think that um
i'm seeing a lot a huge surge in
companies that are hiring
uh consultants for instance to
um to do you know
the introspective work with companies
and teams i think that
there needs to be more coaching for
executives
and i think that so much of it needs to
start at the executive
level you know individually so that
people can ask the questions that
they're afraid to ask in front of a
group of people and
um you know they can get down to the
deeper
issues of leadership um without bringing
the whole company in
and then i do think that this needs to
be an exercise across um
companies and i think there's a feeling
that you know
diversity is a political issue or that
you know these types of talks don't
belong in the workplace and until we get
over that um
we're never going to be able to talk
about it and so
i think that people need on themselves
on an individual level
and then um and then be willing and
courageous enough to have these talks
um as a team i love that thank you thank
you for sharing jennifer
what does it mean to be a consort of in
natural and biodynamic
wines what what is that and how do you
how do you even get that as
a passion yeah so i
actually um started drinking natural
wines
uh with my friends maybe about a year
ago
and that has definitely does that mean
natural what's a natural one am i not
drinking natural wine
um i don't know probably not though
um so natural and biodynamic wines
they're um wines that are uh
created through processes of very
minimal
intervention and so they're typically
used with
organic grapes but organic and natural
wines are not the same
um it's more about the process so
minimal sulfites just minimal chemicals
minimal intervention at all and making
them
and um they're very good for many people
it's an acquired taste
but um you know it's just a
cleaner cleaner drink you're not
hungover the next day
and um they're really delicious and tend
to be coming from
small local farmers much more
sustainable
um farming in general and so better for
the environment as well
wow that's that's wonderful and so what
is actually happening with the with the
wine market today and why is this not a
why is this not a common thing is it
mainly pricing mainly the market
uh so i think it's actually becoming
more and more common
and if you look in your city you will
probably find
um several natural wine makers i think
that
uh or sorry several shops that carry
natural wines i think the biggest thing
is that
um the traditional winemakers are so
they're the incumbents it's kind of like
in tech
and they have all the money and all the
power and they're seeing the
uprise of this new natural wine movement
and i are against it
and typically trying to crush it and so
um
i think that it's just a matter of you
know these smaller growers these smaller
shops
um doing more marketing and figuring out
a way to
convince people that what they've been
doing for all of this time
is not necessarily the best and there's
an alternative that they can get
um for a slightly higher price point it
is a little bit more expensive
depending on what you're drinking
a hundred percent that's it it's very
very interesting and i'm gonna i'm gonna
have to check it out a little bit more
because
i had no idea that this is a this is
even a market or that or that i'm not
drinking natural wine i thought that
when i was drinking wine i was drinking
something very natural
and i feel almost cheated right now so
i'm gonna have to work that with myself
later
but jennifer before we leave i have to
ask you also about your passion for
e-commerce because
we didn't get to talk about that yet but
but that is something that you've been
deeply involved with
with the different companies and you
mentioned that it's a personal interest
of yours
give me a little bit of brief about
e-commerce and why that is something
that you're so excited about
yeah so i think it starts with um
my experience working in startups so
uh the companies that i was at you know
one of them was pure play d2c
ecommerce and then the other two were um
you know ad tech or crowdfunding but had
an e-commerce element
and so all of my professional tech
career has been
in e-commerce through some form and
at the most recent company pop and suki
i
was actually employee number two built
e-commerce from
ground up um from literally nothing and
so
i just understand that
pain points so deeply of you know
internationalization or
logistics and drop shipping um you know
uh conversion and mobile commerce and
trying to optimize and so
it's just something that i know a lot
about and i think as an
investor you tend to gravitate towards
um problems and solutions that you
understand because
at the end of the day you're taking a
bet and you want to take a bet with
um on on companies
for which you have the most possible
context and information
and so um that is definitely why i
gravitate and also as a consumer i love
online shopping i'm constantly on
different e-commerce websites
shopping checking them out seeing what
platform they're using
um how their site set up and so it's
just a
natural passion at the end of the day
i that's uh that's very interesting
thank you jennifer
before we leave i want to thank you for
being generous with your time this was
really really great and i loved hearing
about your journey your interests your
your take on on how we can improve the
tech scene today in the industry as a
whole
and and lastly discovering that i'm i've
been cheated
with my wine drinking so so thank you
for that
but jennifer before we leave i have to
ask you for three words that you would
use to describe yourself
oh um i would say the three words
are adventurous uh sarcastic
and curious i love that
i love that jennifer thank you very very
much this was a really really great
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
this was so much fun appreciated and
happy holidays
you